فالى الاردن اللي ميرا فيها قالبه الدنيا
واصله للبرلمان وعامله حاله غضب من وزاره
الثقافه كمان ميرا هي روايه للكاتب قاسم
توفيق والروايه مجديده لا لها ثلاث سنوات
لكنها عامله جدله اليوم من بعد ما تم
اعاده توزيعها ضمن معارض كتب مكتبه الاسره
لي تابعه لوزاره الثقافه في مهرجان
القراءه للجميع وفي قراء قراوا الروايه
وببداوا الحرب والجدل والغضب اللي الان
مشارك فيه كمان ناس اصلا ما قرات الروايه
والروايه متهمه بالاباحيه والبذاء او انها
بالضم اشياء ما تصلح للنشر وبتخالف قيم
المجتمع من بعد حاله الجدل هذه وزاره
الثقافه طلعت في بيان اعلنت فيه سحب
الروايه من معارض القراءه للجميع في مختلف
مراكز التوزيع كانتيجه لملاحظات الزوار
والبيان مدح في الروائي والتاريخ وشرح
فكره الروايه واكد انه الو سحبتها فقط
مراعاه للسياقه الاجتماعيه والثقافي وانها
ما بتمارس دور الوصايه على القراء وانهم
مقدرين روح النقض والحوار اللي جرحوا
الروايه لكن الجدل والغضب بعد هذا البيان
مهدي وكثر ما عجبتهم لغه البيان اللي صحيح
انه اعلن يعني فيها او اعلن فيها سحب
الروايه لكن ما اذاني الروايه ومن الاصوات
الناقده كانت من جوه البرلمان اللي الازمه
وصلت تحت قبه
اردنيه تحت عنوان مكتبه الاسره الاردنيه
اساءت للاسرى الاردنيه بل واساءت للقيم
الاخلاقيه في الدوله الاردنيه وكان رد
الوزاره باعتبار انا اعتبره اوقح من الذنب
الذي ارتكبه في ماريه الدوله هناك من يسعى
لهدم قيم واعراف والاسس التي بنيت عليها
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه وبيان الوزاره
سعاده الرئيس والزملاء الكرام كان مع
الروايه بعضها فوق بعض ويعبر عن نهج فكري
سمج ومنحرف يصادم الدين والاخلاق وكل قيم
المجتمع انا اطلب من ساعات الرئيس كل
الموظفين المسؤولين عن نشر هذه الروايه ان
يتم محاسبتهم واقانتهم من عملهم وان لا
نكتفي بتشكيل اللجان يعني انا بس بحب احكي
انه هذا عذر اقبح من ذنب اللي ما جاء في
وزاره الثقافه وانا باعتقادي لازم اليوم
فعليا يتوقف عن العمل كل من له علاقه بهذه
الروايه باقترح تكلف لجنه التوجيه الوطني
بمتابعه همم هذا الموضوع بعد ما تاخذ كل
قطرها من انتخاب الرئيس
اغلبيه واضحه
الغضب والانتقادات في الصوت اعلى صحيح لكن
لازم نقول انه مو الوحيد بسبب الانتقاد
كمان مو واحد يعني في ناس من تقدر فكره
الروايه ومضمونها من الاساس ورفضه انها
تنشر اصلا وبطالب بمحاسبه المسؤولين في
وزاره الثقافه وحتى في منهم بيطالبوا
باقاله الوزيره نفسها لكن في ناس ثانيه مع
حريه الكتابه والتعبير بس اعتراض انه
مضمون الروايه لمرحله العمريه معينه وابدا
ما ينفع تكون في مكتبه الاسره او في
متناول جميع افرادها من كل المراحل
العمريه
[موسيقى]